[Musik]
japan wir stehen hier vor einem club den
gretchen du bist auch gleichzeitig
vorsitzende der clubcommission in berlin
was würdest du sagen läuft gerade schief
oder falsch mit den berlinern clubs das
problem ist halt dass sie extrem von
verdrängungen betroffen sind und zwar
von zwei verschiedenen seiten des eines
extrem steigende mieten die dazu führen
dass wir uns das einfach alle nicht mehr
leisten können und auch überhaupt gar
keine rechtliche grundlage haben als
gewerbemieter irgendwo zu bleiben also
es gibt ja kein gewerbemietrecht im
augenblick kein vernünftiges das ist das
eine und das andere
dass es in berlin durch diesen krassen
immobilienboom zu wirklich extreme
veränderungen in der stadt führt also es
kommt halt so extreme verdichtung also
die stadt wächst wir brauchen mehr
wohnungen das ja auch alles total in
ordnung aber durch diese heran an der
wohnbebauung kommt am ende hin zu
konflikten und der club top thema in die
röhre also der club ist immer derjenige
der dann als erstes gehen muss weil es
halt dann mit den wohnungen mit den neu
dazugekommenen wohnungen allerdings eben
nicht funktioniert
es sieht jetzt so aus als hätte die
clubcommission ist geschafft die politik
ins boot zu bringen was könnte sich da
verbessern
also wir arbeiten auf verschiedenen
ebenen wir als klub kommission sind
natürlich hier in berlin
in erster linie daran interessiert die
berliner politik also die landespolitik
davon zu überzeugen dass wir wichtig
sind für die stadt aus vielerlei
hinsicht und nicht nur aus
wirtschaftlicher hinsicht sind wir
nämlich tatsächlich auch wir sind ja
wirtschaftlich arbeitende betriebe
sondern dass er eben auch wichtig sind
für eine die wersestadt für eine urbane
staaten lebende pulsierende stand das
hat die berliner politik erkannt und
auch schon tatsächlich länger und da
sind wir hier in berlin noch ein
bisschen besser aufgestellt als manch
andere städte aber tatsächlich ist es
jetzt so dass wir auch zusammen mit
unserem landesverband der live kommen
auf bundesebene politiker erreicht haben
und es auch auf bundesebene verschiedene
politiker aus wirklich vielen
verschiedenen fraktionen gibt eigentlich
tatsächlich aus allen demokratischen
fraktionen die verstanden haben dass es
wichtig ist dass man die kultur schützen
muss und da arbeiten wir jetzt gerade
daran gemeinsam mit den politikern auf
bundes-
dass sich ein paar gesetzeslagen
verändern damit clubkultur geschützt
werden kann
es gibt jetzt diese initiative die klubs
zur kulturstätten zu machen dass sie
gleichgestellt werden mit theatern opern
und anderen kultur orten was könnte euch
das bringen
es geht darum dass wir im augenblick als
clubs obwohl wir clubkultur machen
rechtlich eingeordnet werden als
vergnügungsstätte also sowas die
bordelle und spielhöllen das hat
verschiedene nachteile baurechtlicher
hat als vergnügungsstätte das so nur in
ganz wenigen gebiets kategorien verortet
sein und bis halt überhaupt nicht
schützenswert also das heißt wenn sich
in den gebieten sich da irgendwas ändert
wenn es um eine verdichtung geht wenn
wohnbebauung kommt dann kann man dem
kann kann auch die verwaltung dem club
quasi nicht helfen wenn wir jetzt
anlagen kultureller zwecke wehren und
gleichgestellt werden wie theater und
opernhäuser zum beispiel würde das a
sozusagen auch das widerspiegeln was wir
sind weil wir sind etwas völlig anderes
als bordelle oder spielhallen oder eben
auch diskotheken wir kuratieren unsere
programme das hätte halt erstmal
irgendwie quasi würden wir einen
gewissen respekt endlich bekommen den
wir auch verdienen und es würde aber
eben auch den verwaltungen und den
ämtern helfen uns zu schützen und eben
bei verschiedenen bauanträgen wo es nur
darum geht kommerzielle hochpreisige
wohnungen zum beispiel zu bauen könnte
auch eine verwaltung dann eher
investieren und sagen ja kann man machen
aber ihr müsst das anders machen weil da
ist ein klub das ist ein kulturort den
wollen wir halten und den möchten wir
halten und den werden wir halten und
deswegen muss sich die wohnbebauung in
den club anpassen und nicht andersrum
was würdest du dir denn für deinen klub
das gretchen wünschen für die nächsten
jahre für die kommenden jahre und wie es
sich weiter entwickeln soll
eigentlich bin nicht dazu da sind wir
sehr zufrieden so wie es ist und wir
haben bei uns wird ja auch
nachverdichtet hier kommt auch
wohnbebauung dazu wir sind aber in einem
politisch guten prozess werden
tatsächlich einbezogen in diesem prozess
das sieht ganz gut aus also ich wünsche
mir für uns für uns natürlich aber eben
auch für alle an
ein leben das wir einfach hier bleiben
können dass wir weitermachen können was
wir machen dass wir weiter
experimentieren kann was eben auch nur
geht wenn wir keine höhere mieten mehr
zahlen müssen
das klar vielen dank für das gespräch
bei mir da wir schauen uns das jetzt
noch andere drin
[Musik]